this growing season farmers in Burkina
Faso won't be harvesting any genetically
modified cotton the government here her
suspended planting of a variety sold by
us agrochemicals giant Monsanto at least
for now it's a victory for environmental
activists alle taps Abba he's worked for
years to get a GM crop called bt cotton
band he says that for farmers the
disadvantages of planting it are simply
too great that won't come back we've
triumphed in the fight against GM cotton
genetic engineering creates a dangerous
dependency on the part of the farmers
and that's not even taking into account
the damage done by BT an environmental
poison we're very happy that
conventional cotton is going to be
planted again this season machete Tom uu
is now busy with the harvest it's hard
work because the crop has to be picked
by hand one drawback of conventional
cotton is that the farmer now has to
spray pesticides on a regular basis
strenuous work and yet you don't earn a
lot but what else can I do there isn't
any other work in Burkina Faso we're
forced to farm cotton whether we want to
or not conventional cotton from burkina
faso is in high demand on the world
markets its fibers are particularly long
and dense a quality the country's
farmers are proud of but Monsanto seeds
produce cotton with shorter fibers
according to the head of the national
cotton producers association karim
traoré
since we adopted GM technology we've
lost our good reputation on the world
markets we've lost the advantage that we
had as a result of the high quality of
our products in Burkina Faso 12% of the
population are directly dependent on the
cotton sector in 2015 there was a record
harvest but buyers stayed away
Elysium GM technology has solved the
problems caused by Hearst's and the need
to use pesticide but now we have the
problem with fiber length we opted out
because we produced a lot but sold
little the farmers of
unday know they need to use less
pesticide when they plant GM cotton and
the yields are higher but many still
prefer the natural crop you only have to
spray once but the seed is poisoned the
entire plant is poisonous that's bad for
your health
but the farmers aren't just concerned
about their own health
they say GM cotton has far more
disadvantages when our animals eat the
leaves they get diarrhea some have even
died and the seeds are very expensive we
have to take out loans to be able to
afford it and if the yield isn't
satisfactory were settled with this debt
forever the Monsanto seeds cost up to 30
times more critics accuse authorities of
selling farmers down the river although
I impose they forced the bt cotton on
them when you look at how GM technology
came to our country it's clear that a
political deal wasn't all system the
system doesn't give farmers any other
choice Aquino faso's future seems to be
heavily tied up with international
business interests cotton is the
country's most important export no one
we haven't abandoned genetically
modified crops entirely but we have to
find a good solution before we go back
to planting them again authorities in
Kenya Ghana and Uganda are soon set to
decide on whether they should also ban
genetically modified crops the reaction
of farmers in Burkina Faso could play a
role in what they decide